[Music]
today's question comes from kevin in
phoenix he says i know you say to put 20
down on a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
but in the market i'm in it feels
unattainable at one point we hit our
savings goal but by the time we saved up
enough the home prices had jumped way up
we're debt-free and we've been renting
for a few years and it just feels like
we'll never be able to buy our first
home we're trying to run the baby steps
but don't see the light at the end of
the tunnel right now is it okay to put
less down in order to get into a house
faster or should we wait for house
prices to come down
well
that question at the end there i'll
answer that first uh maybe both we don't
say you have to put 20 down especially
on your first home
we say it's ideal to put 20 down because
you avoid pmi private mortgage insurance
which is extra money you pay to protect
the lender not you
so as a first-time homebuyer i love that
you're trying to follow the baby steps
you're debt-free you're saving up for
this house and so i'm okay with you
putting less down as your down payment
in order to get into this house and yes
you probably should wait for the housing
market to cool off a little bit so
you're not putting 100 over asking with
no inspection don't do stupid stuff like
that yeah uh prices are not going to
come down kevin
if you're waiting on prices to come down
you're not going to buy a house ever
prices are not coming down
they are going to slow
the rate at which they are increasing
though that's what george is referring
to where the market goes off
right now
asking price means suggest you start
bidding here
and we want to get out of that kind of
thing and you're probably going to see
that we've seen interest rates tick up
the market has slowed down we seem to be
moving into
our second quarter of contraction in the
economy this is known as a recession
and uh
the biden administration seems bound and
determined to create one so it looks
like we're going to be there
and uh that that's where i mean
politics aside it's just observation
and uh the so i think you're probably
going to see
calming down but we've never seen house
prices go down
in the modern america like since the
1930s except one time and that was for
about six or eight months
in 2008
when the bubble burst on the housing
market and it was a t it was a financing
bubble it wasn't a real estate bubble
and so some markets uh phoenix was
particularly hit
uh las vegas was particularly hit a few
other major cities that were super hot
they retr they contracted
and the prices actually went down
but that's the only time i've seen that
and i've had a real estate license 30
years i can't find it anywhere
uh since the what the late 30s
1930s so 100 years almost
and so i don't think you're going to see
house prices go down but we did have
nine was it 20 20 house prices went up
32 right yeah it's crazy and then 21
they went up 14 and they're predicting
in 22 for them to go up seven percent so
we're seeing a a sl the rate of increase
is is less and i think we're going to
continue to see that but i don't think
you're going to see house prices lower
so yes i would buy
uh but don't buy more than a fourth of
your income on a 15 year fix regardless
of what you put down and just understand
you are signing up for pmi which is
about seventy five dollars a month per
hundred thousand borrowed so you buy
three hundred thousand dollar house
you're paying an extra 225 a month for
insurance that is a foreclosure
insurance that
pays the mortgage company if they
foreclose on you it does nothing for you
but that's what private mortgage
insurance is pmi so if you can put five
to ten percent down and it's still a
quarter your take-home pay and a 15-year
fixed rate then beat that thing down and
get it paid down so you get rid of that
pmi even after you buy
turn around get rid of it yeah that's
fine i don't mind that
um and then the other thing you can do
is you could
uh adjust your
desires
but dave it's my dream house it's called
yeah it's a nightmare right now it's
called contentment
okay
the dream house for someone in 1962 was
1 000 square foot
one and a half baths
one story
one car garage one car in the driveway
that was the standard of living of the
average american in 1962.
today
it is a microwave a towel-warming drawer
granite countertops
three-car garage
with electric garage door openers which
when i was a child were only for rich
people
and if you don't have one on your house
now it means you're poverty-stricken
a skylight and a jacuzzi oh gotta have
that skylight
that's living a dog wash
oh that's true i've seen those those are
wild i mean this is standard equipment
now 3 000 square foot two story is the
average home in america
it's gonna so while house prices have
gone up dramatically since 1962 you
can't young kids can't buy a house like
they could in 1962 the average house
price to the average income is
completely out of whack well the average
house is completely out of whack
by the way people think our advice is
well dave ramsey wants you to only save
up and pay cash and you got to wait 20
years and you'll never get a house
you know and by the way you will get a
house so
uh
because a lot there's nothing here
stagnant in the whole process the
the point is you know no one can afford
a car because the value of a car right
now a brand new car as a ratio to income
versus a brand new car in 1970 ratio to
income
is completely out of whack well the
stinking car is out of whack too
i mean these cars are
you know now 50 60 000 as normal they're
wonderful automobiles but by god they'll
fry an egg while you drive to work i've
never seen they do everything
everything rachel's for you don't even
have to drive anymore they'll drive for
you i mean and you know so here's the
thing
i am not saying you shouldn't have nice
things i'm saying your nice things
shouldn't have you and you need to
kind of adjust your
mind
because normal is such a high standard
of living now
compared to a few years ago that you
cannot use
50-year goals statistics
and say that the economy is completely
out of whack and wealth inequality is
lost we've lost our minds because we
haven't what we've lost our minds on is
what we're purchasing